du pays.
(déclic des armes)
- En temps normal, vous auriez
toutes les chances de croiser
Rost
le dimanche après-midi.
Mais aujourd'hui, il apprend
plutôt les rudiments de
la manipulation des armes.
avoir à apprendre, dit-il,
mais dans la situation acte,e,e,
c'est ce qui doit être fait.
Je veux être prêt à tout."
une trentaine comme lui : des
ingénieurs, des atatataticiens,
des professeurs. L'entraînement
ne dure que quelques heures.
concède leur instructeur,
mais ça uauauauand même
le coup."
(déclics de l'arme)
que j'entraîne, seulement
nnnnnnnnent les armes pour tirer
ne serait-ce qu'un seul Russe,
dit Denys, alors mon travail
Pendant qu'ils apprennentà ramr
et à enclencher leurs armes,
à l'étage, Maria, edidididididis
qui seront envoyés aux soldats
au front.
"Il y a beaucoup de médicaments
qu'on ne trouv p p p p p p p p s
pharmacies. Les antibiotiques
et les antidouleurs, on n'en a
plus, en Ukraine", dit-elle.
Avaservait à l'import-export
d'alcool et de fromage.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le point
d'arrivée de tous les dons
en Europe.
Anton était au sommet du mo
Kilimandjaro quand il a appris
que la guerre éclatait
sans attendre. Le guide
touristique a troqué lesdedededs
montagnes de vêtements chauds,
de nourriture et de couvertures.
Son père est Russe et il vit
à Rostov-sur-lululululululululu,
car il ne croit pas à la guerre
famille en Russie ne le croit.
et ils disent encore 'non'".
Les dons, ce n'est pas ce qui
pouvoir les acheminer.
Et que ça se complique.
Marina est responsable de
la distribution des médicaments
aux soldats qu'aux hôpitaux,nsn.
"Il faut agir très vite",
dit-elle.
"Hier, nous avions préparé
dans un village, et comme
le camion se rendait sur place
le village a été détruit.
(déflagrations au loin)
Ils doivent emprunter
où les civils qui cherchent
r r r r r r r risquent leur vie.
Pour une deuxième journée
consécutive, le cessez-le-fe
matérialisé.
(explosions au loin)
Àororororororororororororororo,
une tentative d'évacuation
a tourné au drame. Au moins
trois personnes, des enfants,
de mortiers russes alors qu'ils
cherchaient comme eux à q
leur ville.
qui ont vraiment besoin
i i i i i i i i ne peuvent plus
rester. Nous avons entendu
les promesses de corridors
des corridors de sang qu'ilsonoé
le président Zelensky en soirée.
À Marioupol, tout étaauauauauas
patientaient aux abords dela vi,
sans électricité et chauffage
depuis quatre jo
"Les Russes nous ont menti",
accuse le maire de la ville.
depuis six jours, depuis sixs,ss
sur 24, sept jours sur sept
de tirs constants. C p p p p p z
pas imaginer la cruauté."
Une cruauté qui semcacacacacacf
de Lviv. On devine à peine
la guerre qui fait rage.UkUkUkUv
est le coeur du pays et que Lviv
est son âme. Il en va de même
pour l'effort de guerre. Si Kiev
y envoie toute son âme au front.
Pendant qu'on prie dans
la chapelle, ici, au sous-sol,
nenenenenenenenenenenenenenenens
préparent des rations jour
et nuit. Dans chaque boîte,
un dessin d'enfant et d'autres
"Des cigarettes,
C'est un antistress, dit Oxana,
alors beaucoup de cigarettes."
C'est un devoir, pour elles,'at
avec le sourire.
"Quelqu'un doit le faire,popop"
Dans e e e e e e e e e e e e es
tissent des filets de camouflage
pour les soldats. Lydia vient
presque tous les jours
"C'est ce que je dois faire
uiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiu,
pour ma famille et pour les
autres. Alors, les combattants
ne sont pas seuls à se battre,et
bien peu pour protéger
les soldats qui affrontent
l'armée russe. Au fond,esesesese
qu'un moyen de défense con
l'ennemi; avec chaque maille,
ils fabriquent aussi la fibre
Ici Marie-Eve Bédard,
Radio-Canada,